-Well, here's what everyone's
talking about.
You guys, there was
a huge blizzard
on the east coast today.
On the bright side,
it was nice to see something in
a state of emergency
other than the White House.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Whoa. Hey-oh!
-That's right. Last night,
Trump's top economic advisor,
Gary Cohn,
announced he's resigning.
At this point, so many staffers
have quit,
that when you call
the White House,
Trump answers the phone himself.
He's like...
[ Imitates Trump ] "Hello?
Please hold, I'll connect you.
[ Clears throat ]
The President speaking."
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ] Get this.
Gary Cohn's resignation brought
the total number of officials
who have quit or have been fired
from the Trump Administration
to 19.
19 in just over a year.
-Hey, uh, Jimmy -- you want to
play 10 seconds?
[ Light laughter ]
-What's 10 seconds, Tariq?
-Well, it's where you have
10 seconds to try and name
every departed
White House official.
And it's really hard to do
because there's been so many.
[ Light laughter ]
-No, I actually haven't heard
of that, but it sounds fun.
Can I see you do it?
-Absolutely.
-All right.
Ready? Go!
-Gary Cohn, Hope Hicks,
Rob Porter, Omarosa,
Tom Price, Sebastian Gorka,
Steve Bannon, Scaramucci,
Reince Preibus, Sean Spicer,
Mike Dubke, James Comey,
Mike Flynn, Sally Yates,
Walter Shaub... [ Babbles ]
Brenda Fitzgerald.
-Oh, my God.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪♪♪
That is nothing less
than impressive, my friend.
All right, let me get in
on this.
-Okay. You ready?
-Mm-hmm.
[ Drum roll ]
-Go!
-Gary Cohn, Hope Hicks,
Rob Porter, Omarosa,
Tom Price, Sebastian Gorka,
Steve Bannon,
Anthony Scaramucci,
Reince Priebus, Sean Spicer,
Mike Dubke, James Comey,
Mike Flynn, Sally Yates,
Walter Shaub, Katie Walsh,
Preet Bharara,
Mike McCabe --
[ Buzzer ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Tuba plays
"whomp, whomp" tune ]
-Preet Bharara! Ah!
-[ Laughs ] Pretty fun though,
right?
-Yeah, it is pretty fun.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-Very fun. Very fun.
If you guys watching at home
want to play along, go ahead
and take a video of yourself
trying to say all 19 names
in 10 seconds
and tag it with the hashtag...
Don't forget
the exclamation point.
Ha ha!
[ Laughter ]
And whoever does it the fastest
will have their video featured
on "The Tonight Show"
featuring Jimmy Fallon.
-Wait, wait, come on,
this is my show.
You can't just make up
a contest.
[ Laughter ]
-Please?
[ Light laughter ]
-All right.
Give it up for Tariq and Jamal,
everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
And hashtag -- #10seconds!
-Wow.
Don't forget
the exclamation point.
[ Laughter ]
-You guys see this?
Yesterday Trump told reporters
his idea for how to keep
other countries
from interfering
with our elections.
I'm not sure it's the most
advanced idea. But watch this.
-But it's always good to have
a paper backup system of voting.
It's called paper.
Not highly complex computers.
Paper.
-[ Imitates Trump ] "Paper."
[ Laughter ]
"P-A-Y-P-I-R-E. Paper."
[ Cheers and applause ]
"Google it!"
[ Applause ]
[ Normal voice ]
Then he said, "you know paper,
"the stuff that can be shredded.
That type of stuff,
yeah. Paper."
Here's another story out of
Washington that just came out --
that in his agreement with adult
film star Stormy Daniels,
Trump actually used a fake name
for himself -- David Dennison.
[ Laughter ]
But Trump is denying this
and referred all questions to
his spokesman, Dennis Dennison.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
That's right. In his agreement
with Stormy Daniels --
[ Laughs ]
-Come on!
-What, man? Dennis Dennison.
-This is real.
-Uh...in his agreement with
Stormy Daniels,
Trump used a fake name.
And Stormy said,
"well, he wasn't the only one
faking something."
-Hey, whoa!
-Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
-Hey!
-But today, Stormy Daniels'
lawyer said that she is free
to talk
about her sexual relationship
with Trump.
Americans are like, "Great,
just not while we're eating."
[ Laughter and applause ]
And on CNN last night,
they were talking about
the whole situation, and things
got a little awkward.
Check this out.
And it's part of almost
like the routine
of today's news cycle, which is
the interesting part of it.
-Kevin, are you saying that
a porn star would actually try
to call attention to herself?
Shocking, right?
[ Clears throat ]
[ Laughter ]
-[ Laughs awkwardly ] "Right?
"Yeah. I'm familiar
with porn stars."
[ Laughter ]
"Why so quiet, guys?"
Right now they're still sitting
there in silence.
-Yeah.
[ Applause ]
[ Laughs awkwardly ]
"Right, guys?"
Get this. "Sex in the City" star
Cynthia Nixon
said that she may run
for Governor of New York.
[ Audience oohs ]
And New Yorkers are like...
[ New York accent ] "Oh, thanks,
but we're more of a Samantha."
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Normal voice ]
Oh, are you a fan of the show?
[ New York accent ] You bet!
Manolo Blahniks.
-[ New York accent ] Mr. Big!
[ Laughter ]
-"I make money move!"
-Yeah. [ Laughs ]
Oh! Everybody -- you -- you!
Everybody is still talking about
this week's
big "Bachelor" finale.
You watch it, Higgins?
[ Audience ohs ]
Yeah, it was bizarre, right?
I don't know, man.
I called it from the start,
this Arie dude.
I don't know, man.
But one "Bachelor" fan said
that watching the show has made
her a smarter dater.
Yeah. She said that since
she started watching,
she no longer dates 25 people
at once.
-Oh! Hey!
-That's it. No more. Not again.
Unh-unh. All right,
one more time.
One last time, that's it.
Then I'm done.
Well this was nice.
After Arie dumped her
on national TV,
"Bachelor" contestant Becca
received over $6,000 in Venmo
donations out of sympathy.
[ Audience ohs ]
Becca said that she was touched
by the support,
while Puerto Rico said,
"what the hell?
[ Laughter and applause ]
"You're kidding me, right?
You're joking me?"
[ Applause ]
In other TV news, Nickelodeon
just announced that they're
bringing back
the show "Blues Clues."
[ Cheers and applause ]
They figure at this point,
it's the only way to explain
the Russia investigation
to Trump. Uh, yeah.
[ Applause ]
Finally -- this isn't good.
This week in England, a worker
at a factory that makes
Coca-Cola cans was caught
urinating into the cans.
[ Audience groans ]
But Coke quickly dealt
with the situation by putting
a Mountain Dew label on it,
so no problem.
We have a great show tonight!
Everybody give it up
for The Roots!